no less king h8 and uh i'm telling you  tanya right now i just i  looked around a little bit black is  completely killing it  the plan is simply queen c4 and the mate  on a2 is just terminal  and that's by the way part of the reason  why kj it was necessary because this  bishop check would have soiled the party  and i see a bar has gone down to the  deep  depths of hell right now so white is  busted and this is completely over for  veggie  and i am being told by our producer  sotris that in fact the bar was  absolutely on point and the line that we  were seeing with queen h5 is the way to  go we'll check out what that where white  went wrong but look at this anish wins  way he resigns it's all over here after  king h8 not a single check here on the  board  wow this is that that is the life